it's not something normal it's five kids
absolutely battering each other it's
mental filming House of the Dragon is no
easy feat you know we're going to get
into the intense birthing scene the
brothel all of the intimate scenes that
made the actors extremely uncomfortable
and how a little scene like having lunch
can last for four long brutal days
number one physically and emotionally
one of the most difficult scenes to film
Patty considine uses the word brutal
when describing what the cast went
through that day especially Sean Brooke
it was a massively long day and a very
emotional Scene It was more emotional
than what's finally caught they worked
on a closed set that day nobody who
wasn't supposed to be there was there
and it was mostly a room full of women
the scene shows Queen Emma trying to
give birth to her and King viserys child
but she ends up being forced into a
fatal procedure with the hopes of saving
the child this was a massively physical
day for Sean Brooke there were at least
14 different takes and 14 dresses
handmade specifically for this scene
brutal is definitely a word for it
number two there's bound to be a few
learning a new skill is difficult
especially if it involves fighting with
a dangerous weapon in this case it was
fobby and Frankel and Matt Smith sword
fighting during a rehearsal in an
interview with variety Fabian talks
about how Matt accidentally sliced
himself on the forehead got me right on
the forehead and I've got a right big
forage so it was a pain in the ass they
ended up getting drinks afterward and
celebrating the fact that they both made
it out of their first day remotely
unscathed number three it can be pretty
intimidating reading your own intimacy
scenes as a 17 year old that's right
Emily Carey was 17 when she first read
the script in this instance we're
referring to a scene where she is
bathing King viserys and another where
they're together in bed it scared me
because at that point I still hadn't met
body I didn't know how much of a joy he
was and how easy he was going to make
the scene and all I saw was you know a
47 year old man and me I was a bit
concerned it also helped that they had a
great intimacy coordinator to
choreograph the scenes for them number
four speaking of intimacy this has a lot
Millie Alcock found this scene to be
pretty intense or gnarly rather there
were extras who we had just met who were
like 69ing for 12 hours it's pretty
gnarly we felt pretty overdressed
because everyone else was nude the
director Claire Kilner made sure nobody
saw any of the brothel stuff until the
moment they were shooting so that was
our first time walking through the
brothel and he's guiding her through the
room with all of these other bodies so
that was quite shocking you're like this
is kind of weird and silly number five
did you know a lot of the night scenes
were shot in broad daylight here they
are together both having lost someone
both grieving the chemistry between them
is as strong as before particularly the
scenes shot in drift Mark in episode 7
were later adjusted and color corrected
to look like they were shot at night why
did they do it like this apparently
Elena's funeral was one of the first
scenes they filmed in Cornwall and the
weather would not cooperate in the
slightest it was shot over five days and
we had everything the weather could
throw at us Director of Photography
Fabian Wagner was pulling his hair out
trying to make different scenes look
consistent and continuous HBO even
responded to a Fan's tweet complaining
about how bad the lighting was by saying
it was an intentional creative decision
number six you'd be surprised how
grueling some of these simple scenes are
and it's like day four of like a scene
when you're having lunch that stuff gets
a bit mad doesn't it often times they
would spend days shooting simple scenes
like conversations or yes just having
lunch it's an understatement to say that
actors were getting pretty antsy you do
get that sense of like if you ever leave
this place
number seven yeah not as fun as you
would think it was basically like being
on a 20-foot High bucking bronco but for
like all day once they were up and
strapped in it they'd just leave them
there for hours at a time there's a guy
with a remote control sort of moving you
around they had massive wind machines
blowing into their faces the entire time
they were up there you're strapped in
they're far load of wind and rain aren't
you huh number eight what better way to
introduce you to the targaryens than a
tournament I thought oh it's going to be
in a field with some trees around it and
maybe there'll be some Flags yeah far
from it Jim clay the production designer
showed up with a drawing of a massive
Coliseum she should never have listened
there were so many factors that went
into play when building it especially
when it came to how safe it was for the
performers you know my whole system
and to hurt themselves the Royal box was
a completely separate design in itself I
wanted that to be the dominant part of
the Arena that was quite a costly thing
that talks number nine this time it was
Matt Smith who had an issue with it the
Game of Thrones franchise is known for
its explicit content especially in the
bedroom when asked if Matt Smith's
character has a lot of intimate scenes
his response was yeah slightly too much
if you ask me when filming those scenes
he would find himself asking do we
really need another one to which the
response was always yes we do he
definitely wasn't a big fan of
performing in that way but he also
wanted to honor the world that George
R.R Martin created I guess you have to
ask yourself what are you doing are you
you representing the books or are you
diluting the books to represent the time
we're living in and I actually think
it's your job to represent the books
truthfully and honestly as they were
written number 10 especially when
wearing uncomfortable made for TV armor
Graham McTavish does say that the horse
you get on matters when it comes to how
comfortable your ride will be that day
if you get a good horse you can sit on
with them with anything but one thing
that is consistently unpleasant is
getting on and off the horse while
wearing the armor which was made of
super stiff plastic by the way I've got
to be honest getting on and off the
horse in armor it can be tricky
apparently the Kilts are much more
comfortable when doing scenes on
Horseback number 11. we're talking about
Millie Alcock and Emily Carey they of
course were replaced by Olivia Cook and
Emma Darcy but they appeared together in
many episodes before that I think it was
important and key to show both of these
young women in the early years because
of their strong bond in real life the
scenes where rhaenyra had to be angry
with Allison were a burden for Millie to
perform she explains I adore M and I
feel very protective of her and like her
big sister I don't like being angry at
her in real life and I didn't want to
pretend number 12 so much detail went
into all of these mementos there are all
these wonderful objects and mementos
from his voyages these legendary nine
voyages the crew gave Jim clay and
Claire Nia Richards the set decorator
all the information they have on the sea
snake and let them have free reign on
the designs the detail is unbelievable
it's so beautiful the team had never
designed anything like this before and
everything was made completely from
scratch the concept coming and you look
at some of them you think how the hell
we're going to do that every piece was
influenced by things already made around
the world which details did you notice
when you first watched it number 13 he
really can't catch a break while doing
some stunt work in Portugal Matt Smith
suffered a pretty serious injury to the
disc in his neck for which he faults his
massive armored helmet for he pushed
through the pain to continue shooting
but it probably didn't help as months
after the shooting wrapped he was still
ill and physical therapy for it it's a
pain in the neck literally physically
and metaphorically House of the Dragon
serves up powerful intense birthing
scenes coliseums built from nothing
actors pushing through injuries and
extremely awkward scenes and horseback
riding in bulky plastic armor which
scene do you think was the most
difficult to capture